the idea of running off with the circus  or the carnival was always very uh  strong fantasy for me so i finally got  to do it  you just lean on your memory i remember  as a kid going to side shows those those  memories  are very strong because it was very  scary and very confusing and it was it  was like another world had come to visit  us  fall on your face  [Laughter]  you can't always control all the  situations you're in you can't control  all the aspects of production but what  you can do is make whatever you're doing  authentic and and connected and if you  get outside of worrying about the result  too much and worrying about i mean i'm  conscientious i want people to like the  movies but there's really a point where  you have to let it go you gotta stick  your neck out and  sometimes even flirt with failure  whether i do that or not  it's i like the idea  you